here now with reaction to today's news
Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator one of
the brightest best Debaters according to
Alan dershowitz at Harvard Law uh you're
watching this case uh your observations
am I right about a dual justice system
is this Equal justice under the law or
equal application of our laws
Sean you're you're absolutely right as
you know the last book I wrote is
entitled Justice corrupted how the left
has weaponized the legal system and and
sadly we're seeing it come to life in
Technicolor the book Justice corrupted
talks about how the the Obama justice
department and the FBI and the IRS were
turned into Political weapons to Target
their enemies you just talked about Lois
Lerner that was part of that it then
talks about how those career those those
vicious partisans burrowed into senior
career positions in the agencies and the
Deep State waged war against Donald
Trump during the four years Trump was
President the Deep State tried to do
everything they could to destroy his
presidency now those partisans are back
in the open they are Brazen they are
running the Biden justice department the
FBI the IRS and Sean it gives me no
pleasure to say it this attorney general
Merrick Garland is the most partisan he
is the most most political attorney
general in our nation's history and he
is corrupted the Department of Justice
he has corrupted the FBI he has
corrupted the Machinery of government
and they're perfectly willing to use it
it is effectively an arm of the DNC the
hypocrisy is massive and mark my words I
believe Merrick Garland will indict
Donald Trump he wants to indict Donald
Trump because he hates Donald Trump he
hates him he's angry Merrick Garland is
angry that he wasn't confirmed to the
Supreme Court he wants to indict him I
think the plan was to indict him over
classified documents and then he got the
enormous problem that Joe Biden seemed
to have classified documents everywhere
including in the garage by his old
Corvette I don't think Merrick Garland
will indict Trump over classified
documents here's my prediction
he'll indict Trump over quote
obstruction of justice for hiding the
classified documents now mind you he's
not saying the underlying classified
documents were a crime because he'd have
to indict Joe Biden too he's going to
instead create a crime about a non-crime
that's going to be the basis of the
indictment and I think you're right he
will also indent indict Hunter Biden but
he'll do it on Purely personal matters
dealing with drugs and guns and and tax
issues for Hunter that have nothing to
do with Joe Biden because this doj wants
to protect and insulate Joe Biden and
the Biden family's corruption and they
want to use Hunter Biden as a scapegoat
to justify targeting Donald Trump I want
I want you to focus like a laser on this
issue that you're talking about a
non-crime but issues surrounding a
non-crime uh that they turn criminal and
that being what you believe and I think
I agree with you completely that this
will be this will have nothing to do
with the documents or the rate of
Mar-A-Lago otherwise how would you
justify Hillary Clinton James Comey
acknowledged she had top secret
classified material on her servers no
reasonable prosecutor would prosecute
how do you justify Joe Biden not one not
two not three I think it was four
locations we had classified materials so
if if the special counsel made it about
those issues then America would look
well why didn't you do it to these
people and there is no good answer for
them and what about the idea that okay
well now that we're going to go after
Donald Trump this week for obstructing
an investigation into what they're
saying as a non-crime or not one that
they're going to prosecute okay what
we'll we'll throw you a bone and we'll
arrest Hunter on lying about his gun
application charges that's that's fair
yeah
of course it's not fair and and this is
something I've talked about at Great
length on my podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz where I've talked about here's the
tell the investigation into Hunter Biden
if it stays focused on his personal
issues if it stays focused on drug use
or gun issues or things dealing with
look Hunter Biden is a deeply troubled
soul and the media the corporate media
is prepared to say yeah you know every
family has people who are struggling
with addiction he's someone he needs
help but the tell is does the
investigation cordon off Joe Biden the
reason we care listen if if Hunter Biden
were just some poor schmoe who had real
problems with substance abuse it
wouldn't be a matter of public concern
you and I wouldn't be talking about it
the reason it matters is is Hunter Biden
the evidence suggests made a business of
selling access to Daddy to Joe Biden
selling it to enemies of America selling
it to barisma the Ukrainian natural gas
company selling it to the Chinese
Communists and you're going to have
shortly James Comer and Jim Jordan on
the show look the House of
Representatives is getting ready to hold
Chris Ray in contempt why because the
FBI had a whistleblower come forward and
allege that Joe Biden was personally
involved in a five million dollar
bribery scheme we don't know the details
Comer does but I don't we don't know the
details but my understanding from the
public leaks is it did not concern China
and the FBI as far as we know sat on it
didn't do anything about it didn't
investigate it and so today the FBI
brought the document over to show it to
Comer but said it must remain
confidential and apparently chairman
Comer decided this is serious enough the
American people need to sin so I have a
message for Chris Ray I've known Chris
Ray 25 years
Chris is not a left-wing partisan he's a
company man he believes that he's
protecting the FBI by circling the
wagons let me tell you something Chris
the FBI works for the American people
the American people have a right to have
accountability to know is there evidence
that Joseph Robinette Biden Jr the
president of the United States was
personally involved in bribery from a
foreign Nation don't protect the career
partisans and doj instead put the public
good above parochial concerns the
American people deserve to know what is
the evidence that Joe Biden was
personally involved with bribery
all right Senator very powerful Senator
Cruz thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else